[موسيقى]
في منطقه عربيه منكوبه بالصراعات والازمات
لا يزال الفساد السياسي والاداري والمالي
مستشريا بشكل كبير في هذا السياق لم يكن
مفاجئا ان تتبوا العديد من الدول العربيه
درجات دنيا في مؤشر مدركات الفساد الذي
تصدره سنويا منظمه الشفافيه الدوليه تدرك
هذه الدول ان الفساد هو اكبر عقبه امام
تحقيق التنميه وهو اشبه بالوباء الذي يكلف
اقتصادها مليارات الدولارات سنويا في غياب
اراده سياسيه جاده للتغيير والاصلاح
ومشاركه فاعله من المجتمع المدني ووسائل
الاعلام ما يفاقم عدم الاستقرار السياسي
في المنطقه ويعوق تنميتها الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه فلماذا فشلت معظم الدول
العربيه على مدى العقود الماضيه في اقرار
قوانين فاعله لمكافحه الفساد وما هي
الاستراتيجيات والادوات الاكثر نجاعه للحد
من استشراء هذه الافه وتفعيل الرقابه
والاداريه اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم لم يتغير حال العديد من
الدول العربيه طيله عقود من الزمن وبقي
عنوانه مكافحه الفساد ومحاسبه الفاسدين
شعارا ترفعه الحكومات المتعاقبه دون ان
تنجح في ارسال
اليات فعاله تحول دون استشراء الفساد في
العديد من القطاعات عن التداعيات الكارثيه
لهذا الفساد ومؤشراته يسعدنا ان نستضيف
هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور محي الدين الطوق
الوزير والسفير الاردنيه السابق وهو كذلك
رئيس اللجنه الدوليه المخصصه للتفاوض بشان
اتفاقيه الامم المتحده لمكافحه الفساد من
برلين كندا حتر المستشار الاقليميه للشرق
الاوسط في منظمه الشفافيه الدوليه ومن
باريس مايك مسعود مدير المعدن الامريكيه
لمكافحه الفساد في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا فاهلا بهم جميعا
لا تكشفوا احدث التقارير الدوليه بشان
الفساد عن تحسن كبير في مكافحه هذه
الظاهره ومعالجه اسبابها من الجذور في
اغلب دول العالم وتبدو منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا من اكثر مناطق العالم تاثرا
بتفاقم الظاهره في ظل حاله الصراع التي
تعيشها ودائره الازمات التي تحيط بها واقع
يحيل الى مستقبل قادم ما لم تتغير بعض
السياسات الحكوميه التي توفر بيئه ملائمه
لتفشي الفساد
تنذر مؤشرات الفساد في العالم باتجاه اكثر
دوله الى المنطقه الرماديه التي تتراجع
فيها محددات الشفافيه فمنذ 11 عاما لم
يتغير المتوسط العالمي لمؤشر مدركات
الفساد الذي تصدره منظمه الشفافيه الدوليه
يؤكد اليوم ان اكثر من ثلثي دول العالم
تعاني مشكلات خطيره مع الظاهره
تتقاطع دوائر الفساد والنزاع والامن في كل
مكان ويحفز كل عامل منها الاخر كما يتجلى
في اي استقراء لواقع منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا فسوء استخدام الاموال
العامه او سرقتها او اختلاسها تؤدي الى
حرمان مؤسسات انفاذ القانون والحفاظ على
السلم من الموارد التي تحتاجها لاداء
مهامها
تحرص لذلك منظمات مكافحه الفساد في العالم
على مراقبه سلوك الحكومات في التعامل مع
مساحات الحريه التي يفترض ان تمنح
للمواطنين وللمجتمع المدني تقول منظمه
الشفافيه الدوليه انه يجب على الحكومات
اتاحه مساحه كافيه للشعب في صنع القرار
بدءا من النشطاء واصحاب الاعمال وصولا الى
المجتمعات المهمشه والشباب
في بلد كتونس مثلا يمكن فهم هذه المعادله
جيدا فخلال سنتين الاخيره تركزت السلطات
القضائيه في يد الرئيس اقيل عشرات القضاه
ولم تستانف الهيئه الوطنيه لمكافحه الفساد
عملها منذ اغلقت عام 2021
وفق منظمات مكافحه الفساد فان توجه المثل
هذا يفتح الباب امام الاستبداد وينتزع من
المجتمع المدني قدرته على مراقبه عمل
الحكومات وتلك من اهم محددات القدره على
مكافحه الفساد
عم يسرقون في لبنان تؤكد التقارير ان
انهيار قطاعه المالي منذ عام 2019 ليس الا
نتيجه للانفاق المفرط والفساد وصلت الدوله
الى مرحله عجز عن دفع رواتب الموظفين
وضمان الخدمات الاساسيه مثل الرعايه
الصحيه والكهرباء والمياه وفي ظل حاله
السياسي وغياب اصلاحات حاسمه لكبح جماح
الفساد يخشى ان الوضع لن يؤول الا الى
مزيد من التوتر الاجتماعي
ومثل تونس ولبنان تنظيم مدركات الفساد
اخذه في التراجع في دول اخرى كاليمن
والسودان وليبيا والصومال وسوريا وكلها
انحدرت الى صراع طويل امد غيب الاصلاحات
الضروريه لتحسين الحوكمه الاقتصاديه
والنقديه
وما جرى في دول المنطقه عموما وفقا لمنظمه
الشفافيه الدوليه ان انتفاضات الشعوب لم
تحقق هدف تفكيكها ياكل السلطه وتحول واقع
بعضها الى تجربه مريره مع الصراع العنيف
فاطال ذلك عمر الاستبداد والفساد
وكما جاء في التقرير فقد ظلت العديد من
الدول العربيه تحتل مراتب متدنيه في
مؤشرات الفساد ما يشير الى عز وفشلا من
هذه الحكومات المتعاقبه في التصدي لهذه
الظاهره على مدى السنوات الماضيه
يصنف مؤشر مدركات الفساد 180 بلدا واقليما
من خلال مستوياتها المدركه لانتشار الفساد
في القطاع العام على مقياس يتراوح من صفر
شديد الفساد الى 100 نقطه نزيه جدا ووفقا
لتقرير منظمه الشفافيه الدوليه الاخيره
الصادر لنهايه يناير الماضي يعاني اكثر من
ثلثي بلدان العالم من مشكله خطيره مع
الفساد اذ سجلت درجات اقل من 50 فقد انخفض
متوسط الدول العربيه على مؤشر عام 2022
الى 33 درجه من اصل مئه اغلبيه الدول
العربيه لم تتجاوز درجه 50 على المؤشر حيث
تواصل شعوب المنطقه صراعها مع ما توصف
بانظمه الاستبداد ونضالها من اجل حقوقها
السياسيه والمدنيه والاجتماعيه
احتلت ثلاث دول خليجيه المراتب الاولى
عربيا وهي الامارات وقطر والسعوديه بينما
سجلت السودان وليبيا واليمن وسوريا
والصومال اسوا مستوى للفساد وجاءت جميعها
في ذيل القائمه عربيا وعالميا بقيه الدول
العربيه تفاوتت في تدني درجاتها فجاء تحت
مستوى النصف مباشره كل من الاردن وعمان
والبحرين والكويت
بينما انخفضت تونس اربعه نقاط مقارنه
بالعام الماضي مع تزايد المخاوف من مواصله
البلاد السير على طريق الاستبداد اما
المغرب والجزائر ومصر وجيبوتي وموريتانيا
فجاءت في درجات ادنى وتبقى الفئه التي تضم
كلا من لبنان والعراق في الربع الاسود على
القائمه حيث يعيش كل منهما في دوامه من
الازمات الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والاجتماعيه
دكتور محي الدين توقع اهلا وسهلا بك اهلا
بك رغم كل هذا الحديث عن الفساد ورغم
العديد من القوانين في البلاد العربيه لم
ننجح الى حد الان في الحد من هذه الظاهره
لماذا
كما ذكرت في المقدمه السبب الاساسي هو
غياب الاراده السياسيه من قبل الانظمه
الحاكمه والمسؤولين الكبار في الدوله
هذا الامر لم ياتي من فراغ لانه يرتبط
اصلا
بالرغبه في الاستئثار بالسلطه او ما سمي
ايضا في التقرير النزعه الاستبداديه
التسلطيه
النظام الذي يقوم على هذا الاساس تنشا
حوله مجموعه من المتنفعين والمتكسبين
الذين يحرصون على ان يبقى هذا النظام
بالطريقه التي هو موجود عليها يختطفون
الدوله يختطفون مؤسساتها يختطفون الاقتصاد
ويحققون مكاسب كبيره جدا
الان حتى تعطي الانظمه الانطباع بانها
تقوم بفعل ما لمواجهه هذه الافه الخطيره
وضعت قوانينهم وضع التشريعات انشات هيئات
لمكافحه الفساد وضعت استراتيجيات ووضعت
خطط الا ان الفجوه بين هذه النوايا وبين
التنفيذ فجوه واسعه جدا مما يدل على انه
كل هذه التدابير والاجراءات اخذت من
ما يمكن ان يسمى بانشاء المؤسسات
التفاخريه كما هو الحال في انشاء
مؤسسات طرق مستشفيات شوارع الى اخره الان
الذي الذي جرى ايضا في العالم العربي في
السنوات الاخيره
بان
تفاقم الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه للناس ادى الى زياده على الاقل
شكل واحد من اشكال الفساد اللي هو ما يمكن
ان نسميه الفساد الصغير اضطر الناس
ان يدفعوا رشاوي من اجل الحصول على
الخدمات الاساسيه
وفشل الدوله في تقديم الخدمات الاساسيه في
الدوله الريعيه كما
وصفناها هو الذي يدفع الناس الى ان يلجاوا
الى الواسطه المحسوبيه دفع الرشاوي ماء
الى ذلك لكن الاساسي هو الموضوع
السياسي وفي النهايه ارتبط السياسه مع
الاقتصاد لان اداره الحكم السيء يؤدي الى
تدهور في الاقتصاد وتدهور الاقتصاد يؤدي
الى الحاق الضرر بالقيم الاجتماعيه تبدا
بالظهور ثقافه
تحفيز الفساد بدل ان تكون هناك ثقافه نبذ
الفساد فتتفاعل هذه الامور السياسيه مع
الاقتصاديه مع الاداريه في تفاقم حاله
الفساد وبالتالي لا تنجح الدوله بالمؤسسات
التي انشاتها بالقوانين التي وضعتها
وبالاستراتيجيات التي طورتها في القيام
بمكافحه فعاله في الفساد اذا انطلقنا من
هذا من هذه الفكره نسال السيده كنده حتر
في في برلين منظمه شفافيه
العالميه الدوليه ترفض فكره انه تفوق
الشمال على الجنوب او التفوق الشمال فيما
يتعلق بمكافحه الفساد ولكن مع ذلك نجد ان
المراتب الاولى دائما للدول
الاسكندنافيه الدنمارك فنلندا او غيرها
ما السر في ذلك
اول شيء الفساد هو افا دوليه افا عالميه
ليست مقتصره على مكان دون الاخر لكن ما
يميز مثلا الدول الاسكندنافيه ونيوزيلندا
ان
اليات انفاذ القانون والمؤسسات
الديمقراطيه واحترام حقوق الانسان هو ما
يجعلها قادره على محاربه هذه الافه وايضا
مسائله الناس للمسؤولين ووضعهم ايضا تحت
الرقابه الشعبيه وحسهم ان احسهم الداخلي
المواطنه مفهوم المواطنه القويه الموجود
لدى هذه الدول هو ما يساهم في في مكافحه
هذه الافه بشكل كبير يعني كما قال الدكتور
محي الدين هناك ايضا
اراده سياسيه لكن ايضا يجب ان يكون هناك
قيم في المجتمع وفي المجتمعاتنا العربيه
يجب ان نعمل على على دربين
متوازيين الاول الاراده السياسيه القانون
لكن ايضا القيم المجتمعيه ومحاربه الفساد
من خلال هذه القيم المجتمعيه وليس ان
نحاول ان ناخذ طرقا نتجاوز فيها على
القانون من اجل الوصول الى المصلحه
الشخصيه سواء كنا في السلطه او سواء كنا
ايضا في
مجتمعاتنا الصغيره
فهناك درباني متوازيان عندما يكون الشعب
لديه قيم قيم مكافحه فساده هناك مؤسسات
قويه ومؤسسات انفاذ قانون يكون هناك فعلا
اراده في موضوع مكافحه الفساد اذا هناك
تكامل بين
الحكومات وبين المؤسسات وبين الشعب والراي
العام ومنظمات المجتمع المدني وغيرها في
هذه الحاله سيد مايك مسعود لو نتوقف اكثر
اشاره الدكتور قبل قليل الى ما سماه
الفساد الصغير واشارت ايضا السيده كنده
لهذا الموضوع كيف يمكن لنا ان نتجنب ان
يتحول الفساد الكبير فساد الحيتان الكبار
في المجتمع المرتبطين بالدوله الى ايضا
فساد داخل المجتمع عندما يصبح المواطن
مجبر على دفع الرشاوي وعلى
الاستعداد الدائم لقضاء حوائجه عبر دفع
مبالغ معينه في كل خطوه
الحقيقه كل ما تفضل به الضيوف الكرام انا
اوافق على معظمه لكن في نهايه المطاف
الدكتور طوق ذكر مربط الفرس
وافاد بالجمله من في منتهى الاهميه وهو
النظام السياسي هو الاساس
النظام السياسي استاذي الكريم هو من يحدد
طبيعه وصفه
ومكونات
الوحدات الاقتصاديه في المجتمع
منظومه القوه الباور ستركشر تركيبه القوه
والسيطره في النظام السياسي بتعكس نفسها
تماما مباشره في مؤسسات
المؤسسات الاقتصاديه سواء كانت في القطاع
العام والقطاع الخاص
ومؤسسات المجتمع المدني
تبعا لذلك يتم تشكل منظومه قيم في المجتمع
جديد تتناسق
وتكون متسقه مع قناعات من هم في الحكم
في المراكز من هم من يشكلون النظام
السياسي وبالتالي هي سلسله متكامله لكن لو
سمحت للاستاذ محمد انا لا اتفق ابدا على
تصنيف الفساد لمالي واداري وسياسي هذا قول
حق في اغلب الاحيان يراد به باطل فالفساد
له تعريف واحد فقط لا غير الفساد هو
الفساد حتى في الكتب السماويه لم يصنف
الفساد لكن في العديد من المجتمعات يتم
تصنيف الفساد
واذا اردنا ان نحسن الظن في من يصنف فنقول
اتقوا الشبهات نعم اذا عدنا دكتور توق
لموضوع ارتباط الاستبداد بالفساد لكن هناك
احيانا بعض الظواهر المحيره يعني مثلا
العراق زمن الرئيس الراحل صدام حسين نظام
شبولي مستبد لا مجال فيه لاي لاي حريه
الفساد في ذلك الوقت لا علاقه له اطلاقا
بالفساد المستشري حاليا في العراق وصل
تقريبا 450 مليار دولار على مدى 15 عاما
مع انه توجد صحافه حره وتوجد انتخابات
وتوجد احزاب
ولا يمكن الحديث عن عن قمع لبنان مثلا
مجتمع منفتح صحافه حره اعلام حر قوه
سياسيه ولكن ايضا الفساد مستشري كيف اذا
نفهم هذه القصه
يعني اولا هو لا توجد لدينا معلومات كافيه
عما كان عليه الوضع في ايام الرئيس السابق
صدام حسين طبعا كان حريه الصحافه غير
متوفره حريه الاعلام غير متوفره وبالتالي
ما كان يخرج من ذلك البلد من معلومات كان
محدود محدود جدا الان نتيجه الانفتاح
الاعلامي
اصبحت المعلومات متوافره نتيجه نشاط
المجتمع المدني اصبحت المعلومات متوافره
وبالتالي نستطيع ان نقوم بمقارنات ونستطيع
ان نقوم
بتحليلات الان اذا اخذنا مؤشر مدركات
الفساد لعام 22 حتى اللي في السنوات
العشره السابقه
الدول التي سجلت افضل العلامات هي دول
الديمقراطيات الناجزه ويقع بينها دوله
واحده التي لا يمكن ان تعتبر من
الديمقراطيات الناجزه وهي سنغافوره
بعض المفكرين العرب حاولوا انهم يدفعوا في
الماضي فكره المستبد العادل ولكن في حقيقه
الامر المصطلحين ما بيركبوا على بعضهم
البعض المستبد مستبد ولا يمكن ان يكون
عادلا والعدل نقيض
الاستبداد الان
الموضوع فيما يتعلق بالديمقراطيات الناجزه
في ثلاثه اسس اشارت لهم الاخت كنده حكم
القانون
الديمقراطيه التمثيليه
واحترام حقوق الانسان الان عندما نتكلم عن
حكم القانون الدول العربيه عندما نشات
نشات ككيانات مصطنعه بعد فتره طويله جدا
من
الحكم العثماني
والاستعمار
وهذا النوع من الحكم والاستعمار
لم يؤدي الى نشوء المجتمع وت المجتمع
بصوره طبيعيه وبالتالي عندما قامت الدوله
المؤسسات الاجتماعيه كانت ضعيفه جدا
وحكم القانون بالتالي كان ضعيف والدوله
العربيه الحديثه استمرات هذا الموضوع لان
بقائها في السلطه هو شيء مهم جدا بالنسبه
لها فاذا كان بده يطبق
المساءله
فيطبق على الجميع على الصغير والكبير اذا
كنا بدنا نطبق الرقابه الرقابه يجب ان
تطبق على الجميع جميع المؤسسات من اعلى
سلطه في الهرم السياسي الى الى ادنى الى
ادنى سلطه ولكن احب ايضا ان اعقب على شيء
حكته الاخت كنده بانه صحيح انه قيم
المجتمع مهمه جدا
ولكن
الفساد مثل السرطان اذا انتشر في الجسم
يقتل الجسم بشكل نهائي
الفساد اذا انتشر في السلطه
قيم الناس بتبدا تتغير حتى تتلائم مع هذا
مع هذا النظام
احنا في مجتمعاتنا العربيه والاسلاميه في
الاسلام الحنيف القيم المتعلقه بالعدل
والكرامه
والاحترام الاخر واحترام المال العام قيم
ساميه وعاليه جدا في ثقافتنا ولكن نتيجه
يعني الاستبداد اللي جرى في الخمسين سنه
الاخيره على الاقل او سبعين سنه الاخيره
خلت قيم الناس شويه مهزوزه الان بالمقابل
نحن في عندنا الان ناس
يعني يفتخروا بانه وفي امثله العاميه يعني
في اللغه العربيه
بيفتخروا فيها الناس ان هم والله
قادرين على انهم ينهبوا
وواقف على رجليه وشاطر
فالقيم الاجتماعيه
ما في شك بانها في غايه الاهميه ولكنها
تضعف بشكل كبير جدا ازاء الفقر ازاء
التهميش في النهايه الانسان العادي بده
يعيش بده يلبي حاجاته الاساسيه واذا اضطر
ان يدفع الرشوه فسيدفع الرشوه من اجل ان
يحافظ على حياته حياه ابنائه هناك ايضا
ظاهره دكتور الحقيقه في ترتيب الدول الاقل
فسادا في المقدمه نجد ثلاث دول الخليجيه
الامارات
قطر السعوديه الامارات مثلا
عالميا 27 قطر اربعين السعوديه 54 الحقيقه
هذا ملفت للنظر لانه هذه ثلاث دول دول
غنيه يفترض يفترض بين قوسين ان هذه الدول
والوفره الماليه التي فيها تشجع اكثر على
الفساد كيف نفسر ان الدول الاكثر غنى هي
اقل فسادا بينما نجد دول فقيره معدمه نسبه
الفساد فيها كبير
انا انا باعتقادي في هناك سببين سببين
اساسيا السبب الاول هو الرخاء الاقتصادي
الناس في دول الخليج وهدول الدول الثلاثه
اللي ذكرتهم مرتاحين ماليا ومرتاحين
اقتصاديا والسبب الاخر هو فاعليه هذه
الحكومات اذا اخذنا مؤشرات الحوكمه
الدوليه لدى البنك الدولي نجد بان الدول
الخليج تحصل على علامات مرتفعه في المؤشر
الفرعي المتعلق في فاعليه الحكومه في هناك
سته مؤشرات اساسيه في مؤشرات البنك الدولي
احدها فاعليه الحكومه واحد اخر ايضا اللي
هو فاعل فاعليه الهيئات التنظيميه دول
الخليج قطعوا في هذا المضمار شوط شوط جيد
وبالتالي
التقارير الدوليه اللي عمها بتصدر من جهات
متعدده وهي كثيره
هي في صالح في صالح هذه الدول
وبالتالي لانه الناس مرتاحين ما بدفعوا
رشاوي
ما بلجاوا الى الواسطه والمحسوبيه للحصول
على الخدمات والحصول على الاحتياجات
الاساسيه لهم نسبيا نسبيا نسبيا
الدول الاخرى اللي انت ذكرتها يعني
يمتزج فيها
الاستبداد وحاله العوز الاقتصاديه
والماليه اللي هي يعني
معادله
بتشجع الفساد وبتشجع الناس على انهم
يلجاوا
الكل في موضوع الفساد هناك عدد من
المنظمات والهيئات الاقليميه والدوليه
التي ترصد هذه الظاهره تقيمها وحتى تسند
جوائز في مجال مكافحته نتعرف على بعضها
على الاقل
تشفافيه الدوليه وهي منظمه دوليه غير
حكوميه معنيه بالفساد وتعمل في اكثر من
مئه دوله لانهاء الفساد تاسست في عام
1993 بالمانيا منذ العام
1995 بدات باصدار مؤشر فساد سنوي وتنشر
ايضا تقريرا عن الفساد في العالم
اتفاقيه الامم المتحده لمكافحه الفساد هي
الصك العالمي الوحيد الملزم قانونيا
لمكافحه الفساد ومن ابرز ما يميز
الاتفاقيه ادراج فصل خاص بشان استرداد
الموجودات بهدف اعادتها الى اصحابها
الشرعيين بما في ذلك البلدان التي اخذت
منها بطريقه غير مشروعه
المنظمه العربيه لمكافحه الفساد تاسست عام
2005 واتخذت بيروت مقرا عاما لها تنظر
المنظمه الى الفساد في الوطن العربي
باعتباره مرضا يهدد النمو الاقتصاديه
وحركه التنميه
جائزه الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني الدوليه
للتميز في مكافحه الفساد تقدم هذه الجائزه
سنويا في اليوم العالمي لمكافحه الفساد
وتقدم تكريما وتقديرا للافراد والمؤسسات
ممن ساهموا في الحمله العالميه لمكافحه
الفساد
والدكتور محي الدين توقفه اخر جائزه كانت
من نصيبك نسال السيده
كنده في بالنسبه
لمنظمه شفافيه الدوليه 95% من الدول لم
تسجل تقدم في مجال محاربه الفساد منذ 2017
كيف نفسر ذلك رغم كل هذه الحملات ورغم كل
هذه المنظمات وتقاريرها وهي تقارير صريحه
ولادعه احيانا
اذا بتسمح لي في نقطه يجب ان نركز عليها
مؤشر مدركات الفساد يقيس الفساد في القطاع
العام يعني نحن نتحدث في نقطه قبل قبل
التقرير تطرقت الها مع الدكتور محي الدين
عن دول الخليج مثلا او عن الدول المتقدمه
اقتصاديا او ذات الرصادي
الفساد في القطاع العام هو ما يقاس ضمن
هذا المؤشر هناك فساد في القطاع الخاص لا
يتضمن في هذا المؤشر وبالتالي هو ايضا في
هذه الدول فيها قطاع خاص كبير جدا لا يمكن
قياسه فبالتالي لا يمكن ان نقول ان هناك
ان هناك شقا شقا متكاملا في موضوع مكافحه
الفساد وبالتالي قياس مؤشر دول فهذا
الموضوع يجب ان ان نلقي الضوء عليه بشكل
اساسي لاننا نتحدث ايضا عن معايير معايير
كثيره لها علاقه في في قدره الناس على
الحصول على الخدمات الخدمات العامه
95% من دول العالم اللي لم تحرج تقدما لم
يكن هناك
ضخ في موضوع تحسين الخدمات بان لا يكون
فيها فساد وفي هذه المؤسسات داخل هذه
الدول ونحن ايضا تعرضنا لجائحه كبيره ايضا
جائحه الكورونا ادت الى تاكل في كثير من
هذه الخدمات وخصوصا القطاع الصحي
والقطاعات الاخرى ايضا تاثرت فيه تلقائيا
حيث ان الاقتصاد بشكل عام تاثر بشكل كبير
وبالتالي كان له اثرا كبيرا في التراجع
هناك عوامل ايضا مختلفه يجب النظر اليها
يعني نحن نتحدث عن في بعض الدول مثل
المانيا على سبيل المثال هي ثالث او رابع
اكبر اقتصاد في العالم لكنها ايضا ليست من
الدول المتقدمه جدا على المؤشر نعم هي من
العشرين دوله الاولى على المؤشر لكن فيها
فيها اشكال من الفساد موجوده
وهناك وهناك ايضا تقارير تتحدث عن قدره
الاقتصاد حتى لو كان اقتصاد قوي وارتباطه
بالديمقراطيه والمؤسسات القويه والمساءله
فنحن نتحدث عن عن فساد في قطاع واحد وهو
القطاع العام وليست القطاعات الاخرى في
بعض الاحيان يجب ان ننظر الى الصوره بشكل
شمولي اكثر من فقط وضعها على المؤشر
واعطائها على يعني نحن نستخدم المؤشر
كمؤشر يعني من اسمه دلاله على ان هناك يجب
التعامل معها لكن تحليلها يجب ان ياخذ
بعين الاعتماد جميع جميع العوامل المرتبطه
في موضوع الفساد في الدوله ولكن السيده
حتى ما الذي يبنى من رصد اي فساد في
القطاع الخاص خاصه ان القطاع الخاص خاصه
في الدول العربيه تجد رجل الاعمال هذا او
الشركه الفلانيه لها حظوه لانها قريبه من
رئيس الدوله قريبه من صهر قريبه من زوجته
وبالتالي شبكه علاقات اجتماعيه
تشجع على الفساد في القطاع الخاص حتى وان
تركنا جانبا القطاع العام
هو ليس مستحيلا ان يتم قياسه هناك مؤشرات
اخرى وهناك دراسات اخرى
تدعم ايضا موضوع مؤشر مدركات الفساد في
القطاع العام لكن هو
القدره على التحليل والحصول على المعلومات
لان القطاع الخاص كما قلت هو هو يتحكم في
كل الاوراق لا يمكن الوصول اليها لا يمكن
الوصول الى المعلومات في القطاع الخاص
بشكل بشكل كبير مثل ما يمكن الحصول عليها
في القطاع العام وتحليلها هناك ايضا يعني
مؤشر مدركات الفساد يقيس العلاقه ما بين
القطاع العام والقطاع الخاص طبعا لان هناك
تضارب مصالح وهذا يتم قياسه من ضمن الفساد
في القطاع في القطاع العام لكن هناك مثلا
موضوع غسيل الاموال او الملاذات الضريبيه
الامنه التي تسمح للشركات بان يكون لديها
سجل مستفيدين غير معلن
للتهرب الضريبي هذه امور مثلا لها علاقه
في القطاع الخاص ولا تدخل ضمن اجراءات
القطاع العام او الخدمات التي يحصل عليها
الجمهور فبالتالي هذا القطاع له له دراسات
ومؤشرات اخرى يجب النظر اليها لانه في بعض
هذه الدول يعني مثلا بريطانيا المملكه
المتحده تعتبر تعتبر احدى الملاذات
الضريبيه الامنه التي يمكن من خلالها غسيل
الاموال بشكل كبير في قطاع العقارات مثل
ما دبي ايضا اعلنت كنوع من
المقر لكثير من هذه الشركات العابره فنحن
نتحدث عن ايضا عالم موازي للقطاع العام
ويجب ان ننظر الى الصوره بشكل شمولي اكبر
وربما ما يزيد في تعقيد هذه الصوره سيد
مالك مسعود ان محاربه الفساد على الاقل في
الدول العربيه
نوع من الحملات واغلبها تدخل في اطار
تصفيه حسابات بمعنى لا تدخل في اطار
شفافيه مبنيه على مؤسسات وقوانين وانا ما
تاتي حملات احيانا لوبي يضرب في لوبي اخر
فكيف يمكن ان تضر هذه القصه هذه
المناسباتيه وهذه الانتقائيه في محاربه
الفساد في معالجه الظاهره كاساس
الحقيقه زي ما انا بدي اشكر الست كنده على
التوضيح الدقيق للغايه اللي هو الفساء او
او السي بي اي والمؤشر المدركات الفساد له
علاقه فقط في قطاع
العام وليست لها علاقه بالقطاع الخاص لانه
مجال بدي اجاوبك على سؤالك السابق اذا
سمحت لي
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مركز
الدراسات الشهير في سنه في سبعه في
12/7/2020 قال انه دوله خليجيه احد المدن
فيها اما مقرا اما بتكون هي مقر لغسل
الاموال او تشكل مرورا لغسيل الاموال هذا
يفسر التضارب ما بين مثل هذه التصريحات
والمراكز المتقدمه في الدول العربيه حول
مؤشر مدركات الفساد لكن الان حتى اجاوبك
على سؤالك واجاوب على ملاحظه اخرى على
الدوله الوطنيه اذا ارادت ان يكون هناك
استدامه في وجودها لانه الفساد ويهدد
الوجود على فكره والدليل على ذلك انظر الى
لبنان
اذا ارادت الدوله الوطنيه محاربه الفساد
فعليها ان تماسس هذه المحاربه هذا واحد
اثنين يجب النظر واعاده النظر في
التعاطي مع ظاهره الفساد على انها تهديد
وجودي امني وعلى انه لا يمكن على الاطلاق
ان ترضي لانه القادم من الايام والسنوات
القادمه هو عباره عن تقييم العلاقات
الدوليه بناء على محاربه الفساد لانه
محاربه الفساد خرجت من الاطار المحلي الى
الاطار الدولي غسل الاموال يؤثر على
وتمويل الارهاب يؤثر على سياسات دول في
العالم كله عشان هيك لا يوجد اي مصداقيه
لاي عمليه مكافحه فساد لا تتم بشفافيه
وعلنيه وطبقا لصيانه القانون والحكم
الرشيد وامور اخرى عدا عن ذلك كله ذر في
العيون وهذا لا يخفى على المجتمع الدولي
اكثر من اللازم الامور باتت مكشوفه على
فكره في المنطقه العربيه وفي الدول
العديده جدا حتى في اوكرانيا طلع هي طالما
هي مكشوفه لماذا مثلا بعض بعض الدول التي
سعت
مصر ليبيا تونس ساعه الاسترداد ما يوصف
بالاموال المنهوبه اموال هربت للدول
الاوروبيه
عديده من قبل انظمه سابقه ولكن عندما جاءت
انظمه اخرى وسعت بجديه متفاوته للحقيقه
لاسترداد هذه الاموال لم تفلح في ذلك هل
النظام الدولي يحمي يحمي الفساد بشكل ما
اي نعم نعم سيد مايك
الاجابه بدون اي مواربه النظام الدولي
نحكي عن الدول الكبرى تستخدم الفساد خارج
دولها كاداه تحقيق لسياساتها اذا كانت
الدوله والمسؤول قابل للافساد
يرحبون به وهم بالجهه الاخرى يرسلوا الدول
الاموال
كاموال ممنوحه للدول لكي تساعدهم اذا في
نهايه المطاف فيما يتعلق بالسداد الاموال
المنهوبه هناك تقصير من الدوله الوطنيه من
بعض الدول التي ذكرت واعتقد ان النائب
العام القطري قد تم تعيينه في السابق
كمفوض او كممثل اللي هو المتحده للاسترداد
الاموال المنهوبه لكن مع الاسف هناك اموال
ليست فقط في العالم الغربي وهناك اموال
هربت للدول العربيه
وبالتالي بعض الدول العربيه
تضع العقبات لسداد مثل هذه الاموال وبعض
العديد جدا من الدول تستقوي بالاجنبي حتى
لا يتم اعاده مثل هذه الاموال لانه انت
تعلم المال هذا يساوي اقتصاد وبالتالي
المشكله نعم معقده لكن كيف كيف يمكن حل
مثل هذه المشكله بهذا التعقيد ايجابي
بتعود لك ايمتى بدك نعم في اطار مؤسسه
محاربه الفساد التي اشار اليها السيد مايك
مسعود الدكتور طوق يعني القضايا يلعب دور
اساسي يفترض في اي نظام يقوم على مؤسسات
وعلى توازن بين السلطات القضاء يفترض ان
يحسم في الامور هل ايضا المعضله في اغلب
الدول العربيه انه الفساد
مرعي سياسيا ومحمي ولكن ايضا القضاء ضعيف
الى درجه واحيانا فاسد هو نفسه ولا يستطيع
ان يحسم في هذه القضايا
قبل ان اجيب على هذا السؤال اود ان اضيف
الى ما قيل من قبل الزملاء لا فاضل
العالم الاقتصادي الشهير الحاصل على جائزه
نوبل في الاقتصاد يقول بان مجمل ما يتم
تسريبه من اموال من الدول الناميه الى
بنوك الدول
المتقدمه والدول الغربيه بالذات يفوق مجمل
المساعدات التي تقدم الى هذه الدول
الناميه وبالتالي فهي تجاره رابحه
هذه هذا ما احببت ان اقوله والبنك الدولي
لديه بيانات يعني متعدده في في هذا المجال
من
الدراسات اللطيفه اللي بتقوم فيها منظمه
شفافيه دوليه على سبيل المثال
الاشي اللي نحن المسمى بارومتر الفساد
منظمه شفافيه الدوليه عملت اكثر من دراسه
في الاقليم العربي
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
اظهرت
التقارير اللي اصدرتها منظمه شفافيه دوليه
بان الفساد تغلغل الى كل القطاعات بما في
قطاع القضاء ولو كانت بنسب يعني اقل ولكنه
وصل الى
القضاء السبب في ذلك كما هو معلوم وهذا
ليس سرا بان السلطه التنفيذيه في معظم
الدول العربيه
تغولت على السلطات الاخرى سواء كانت سلطه
التشريعيه او السلطه القضائيه وفي فهم في
تونس اصبحوا يسموها وظيفه وظيفه القضاء
وليس حتى سلطه يعني مثلا
فيما يتعلق بتسريب الاموال الى الخارج
القضاء الوطني يجب كان ان يبت بت قاطع بان
هذه الاموال التي تسربت الى الخارج هي
كانت نتيجه افعال الفساد لان هذا الحكم
القضائي الصارم من قبل سلطه قضائيه مستقله
وليس سلطه قضائيه مسيره من قبل الحكومات
هو الذي يساعد في استرداد الموجودات من
الخارج هذا عامل مهم وهذا عامل مهم جدا
انا شاركت في جهد دوله فيما يتعلق بهذا
المجال
المنظمه الشفافيه الدوليه تعلم هذا الامر
وكندا تعلم تعلم هذا الامر بالذات وكما
قلت اخي محمد بان الدول العربيه المعنيه
في ذلك الوقت لم تكن جاده في الطلب
استرداد الاموال اللي موجوده عندها لم تكن
جده ولم يكن لديها الادله ولا المستندات
لديها على الاقل لم يكن لديها الادله
والمستندات ولم تصدر احكاما قضائيه نهائيه
من قبل سلطاتها الوطنيه القضاء الوطني
تبعها وبالتالي عندما ذهبنا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وقلنا لهم يا جماعه هذا ما بيجوز
فقالوا لنا انتم بدكم تكونوا ملكيين اكثر
من الملك الدول المعنيه لم تطلب ولم تقدم
ادله ولم تقدم ادله كافيه وعلى سبيل
المثال الدوله العربيه الوحيده اللي رجعت
اموال لتونس هي لبنان الدول الاوروبيه ما
رجعت ولا اشي لبنان رجعت حوالي 25 مليون
وايطاليا رجعت يخت كان موجود
لتونس
الحاكم التونسي السابق ولكن الدول الغربيه
تتحجج بموضوع القضاء
وتتلكى في اعاده الاموال الى الدول
وبالتالي الحقيقه اللوم يقع على الجانبين
جانب الدول المرسله التي لا تقوم بوظيفتها
بشكل جيد وجانب الدوله المستقبله التي
تحاول ان تتلكى اكبر قدر ممكن من الزمن
طالما انه الاموال مدعاه مدعى لديه ايضا
من الافكار التي تساق دائما عند الحديث عن
الفساد دكتور طوق وان الفساد ايضا يعيق
ويعطل اي تنميه اقتصاديه
هل من شرح لهذه المساله لان البعض ربما
يقول ما علاقه هذا بذلك يا سيدي
البرنامج المائي للامم المتحده يقول ما
يليه
اذا استرجع مليار واحد فقط من الدولارات
للدول الناميه فبهذا المبلغ يمكن
وصل
250 الف مسكن لشبكات المياه
ويمكن بناء 3000 مدرسه
ويمكن توفير مطاعيم
لمليار بني ادم
ويمكن بناء 3000 مدرسه كما قلت ويمكن ايضا
بناء 2500 كيلو متر من الطرق المعدده الان
كل هذه الامور تصب في التنميه بناء
المدارس الطرق المعبده التطعيم وما الى
ذلك اكبر شيء يلحق اذى في التنميه
الاقتصاديه المتكامله هو استشراء استشراء
الفساد الذي تسرب من الدول العربيه
حسب تقدير منظمه شفافيه دوليه حوالي 165
مليار دولار
الان تصور هذا الكم من المال ماذا يمكن ان
يصنع من اجل
مياه نقيه مدارس جيده صح متقدمه رعايه
اجتماعيه قضاء على الفقر خلق فرص عمل
القضاء على البطاله وبالتالي يعني الحديث
عن العلاقه بين الفساد والتنميه حديث عميق
ويجب ان يعني ياخذ مداه لانه اصلا احد اهم
اسباب فشل التنميه في العالم العربي هو
ظاهره
الحكم غير الرشيد
واستشراء الفساد
طبعا السيده كنده وسيد مايك موضوع الفساد
موضوع متشعب وطويل ولكن اذا اردنا ان ننهي
هذه الحلقه بشكل مختصر من كل ضيوفنا نبدا
بالسيده كندا ثم السيد مايك وننهي مع
الدكتور طوق في
ظل هذا التعاقد في المشهد
ما اول خطوه على الاقل في هذه الظروف
الحاليه التي يجب على الحكومات العربيه ان
تقدم عليها للحد على الاقل من استفحال هذه
الظاهره
هناك نقطه اساسيه يجب ان نضيء عليها
الحريات العامه المسائل الاجتماعيه
المجتمع المدني الصحافه الحره غير المقيده
وايضا عدم ملاحقه المبلغين عن الفساد هذه
الامور ايضا تكامليه ولكنها اساسيه يعني
يجب ان لا نضع العائق فقط على الاراده
السياسيه لكن الاراده السياسيه دون وجود
هذه العوامل وهذه الحريات لا يمكن ان يكمل
عمليه مكافحه الفساد لان المواطن هو ما
يلمس الفساد المباشر سواء من من سوء
الخدمات من من سرقه الاموال العامه من
ايضا عدم حصول حصوله هو او حصول اولاده
على حقوقه الكامله وايضا عدم قدرته على
التصويت الحر من اجل ان يكون لديه قياده
سياسيه يمكن ان تكون ديمقراطيه تستطيع ان
تضمن الحكم الرشيد هذه العم
ليه يجب ان تكون متكامله بمشاركه الجميع
وايضا اهداف التنميه المستدامه حتى نقوم
بتحقيقها يجب ان تكون عمليه تشاركيه
وفعاله ويجب ان يكون هناك احترام لحقوق
الانسان سيد مايك مسعود
اعتقد انه يجب تطبيق عده امور فورا عن
الاعتقادي اذا ارادت الدول ان تحدث تغييرا
جوهريا ملموسا بمكافحه الفساد اولا طبعا
يجب ردم الهوه الثقه ما بين المواطن
والدوله هناك
فجوه واسعه جدا
بعدم الثقه ما بين المواطن ومؤسسه الدوله
لنبدا بما يلي يجب الدوله ان تقوم بتعزيز
سياده القانون ثم تعزيز الحوكمه الفعاله
سواء بقطاع الخاص او قطاع العام تعزيز
انظمه الرقابه الداخليه بالمؤسسات القطاع
العام والخاص قضاء مستقل وفعال يجب ان
تفعل ذلك وتؤكد المواطن انه يوجد قضاء
فعال لا تشوبه شائبه يجب ان يكون هناك
مواءه من بين السلطه والمساءله
اذا كان قد يكون عندك سلطه يجب ان تكون
مسائله ويجب ان يكون هناك استثمار في
الوقايه من الفساد بالدوله كما مع الاسف
جدا انا بدي اقول انه ما في استثمار في
مكافحه الفساد في العالم العربي زي ما فيش
استثمار في البحث العلمي ثم على الدوله ان
تفكر جيدا وتشرع ما يسمى
انه لا يوجد
يعني ما فيش للفساد
دكتور طوق في النهايه باختصار رجاء
ماذا علينا ان نفعل الان على الاقل في
المدى القريب والسريع هناك قول ماثور
للامام علي ابن ابي طالب
يقول
عدلت فامنت فنمت والعدل اساس الملك
وبالتالي المبدا الاساسي يبدا من الاراده
السياسيه والرغبه الحقيقيه في الاصلاح
لبناء نظام نزاهه وطني متكامل لا يمكن انه
تصطلح الامور
باصلاح جانب واحد لابد من ان يتناول
الاصلاح كل الجوانب
ومنظمه شفافيه الدوليه عملت على هذا
الموضوع في ال25 سنه الاخيره نظام النزاهه
الوطني له اعمده 13 عمود واذا لم يتم
الاصلاح بشكل شامل لهذه الاعمده والاركان
كلياتها مع بعضها البعض بشكل شامل ومتكامل
لن تصطلح الامور وعلى راسها الاراده
السياسيه والرغبه الحقيقيه في الاصلاح
شكرا لك دكتور بدانا بالاراده السياسيه
وانتهينا بالاراده السياسيه شكرا لك دكتور
محي الدين توك شكرا ايضا للسيده كندا
ايضا للسيد مايك مسعود بهذا المشاهدين
الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]